oh man we are back let's talk about more
space guns
those of you not daunted by our review
score may well be enjoying the looter
shooter that is now Mass Effect
Andromeda you've already got your base
load outs dialed in but maybe
something's off like beating up ket on
Normal difficulty just doesn't do it for
you like it used to
well you're in luck because after our
last five guns you'll love in Mass
Effect video we reached out to you for
your sick loadouts and boy did you
deliver let's crank the game up to
insane difficulty and look at six more
guns you'll love in Mass Effect
Andromeda give us the thumbs up if you
want even more guns after this and
subscribe to our Channel although I
can't promise you all ever actually be
able to find P B's backwards hand cannon
oh crap crap crap the first gun we
dubbed the vampire laser comes from
commenter brock Nealon who said use a
remnant assault rifle that shoots a beam
with the mod that instant reloads for
some health loss never run out of ammo
and shoot a constant beam of get the
[ __ ] out of my way we figured vampire
laser
oh that sounds oh good god
this might be one of the most powerful
guns we've put together so far mix one
part remnant Paul assault rifle and one
bio converter mod that instantly reloads
by sucking down character health and
don't forget to boost any health
restoring stats in case you go a bit
overboard on the whole drain yourself
thing may be to death we installed the
bio converter mod after working around a
bug that makes this mod disappear unless
you also research shield sensors if you
find yourself facing down a big baddie
and too low on your own blood to finish
make sure to stock up on Cobra RPGs that
can be found at the end Garen market on
hvar oh and can save your ass just the
same way does in multiplayer hvar o is a
great place by the way to buy resources
if you're coming up short next up for
the budding space gun nut is the in the
words of Acadia 671 remnant sweeper
assault rifle with homing plasma augment
it's on heatsinks so no need to pick up
ammo crates and you can hit anything
even things in cover what else do you
really need Acadia six seven one hits on
a critical point for those taking on
Andromeda at insane difficulty you will
both be taking a lot more cover and
laying down a lot more blind fire than
in normal or hard mode this is where the
homing plasma augment is key to hitting
targets without too much aiming Plus at
some point you will run out of lead from
the Milky Way and plasma from the Helius
cluster so always pack backup remnant
weapons because they never run out of
murder lasers it goes without saying max
out combat fitness so that you're able
to carry four guns instead of two next
up Scallon 15 mentioned one of our
favorite SMGs by saying the n7 hurricane
that's all you need user
mrow added craft with the secret plasma
augment man you guys really love your
secret plasma it's a great
recommendation we went without it but
the n7 hurricane rips out 925 rounds a
minute out of the box this throaty
sounding dream has a bit too wide of a
shot pattern
a pistol scope and investing points into
the pistol combat tree can bring that
muzzle under control
combine that with pistol magazine mods
and rank five pistols to get the clip
size upwards of 70 to finally top that
off with your favorite consumable ammo
type for freezing or sizzling Raiders
now word from our Quarian sponsors we'd
like to take a break from our
user-selected weapons to bring you the
Rieger carbine shotgun this weapon is of
korean design and is basically a cattle
prod on crack designed to kill get it is
a dream against non-organic life forms
and is a great weapon to have by your
side in vaults Riegert because sometimes
machines are dicks alright let's get
back to your guns
previously we fell in love with the
Scorpion pistol and it's sticky blobs of
death commenter juku kunitoshi thought
we could do better when pointing out the
cyclone v with sticky grenade mod
roughly 80 mini grenades exploding on
foes well after a bit of fluid sac
hunting we finally caved in and bought
them on hvar oh we had the grenade hose
up and running in terms of time to kill
it landed in the okay to moderate range
and this build has a bit more bark than
bite this one seems like it'd be a lot
of fun but probably in normal mode
we would like to test this build in our
next video on the cat sonnet assault
rifle basically a mini gun with a higher
rate of fire and larger clip size let us
know if you've had any luck with great
sticky grenade builds with that one not
quite working out we decided to stay
away from the fray with a recommendation
from tyler Holdsworth who pointed out
GameSpot there are awesome weapons but I
personally rocked the revenant Black
Widow and a sorry sword with enemies on
insane difficulty you should consider
minding your distance and the Black
Widow is the 50 caliber sniper rifle of
the Andromeda universe that tactical
cloak though ought to let you get close
and the asari sword also plays into this
ninja build granting you a split second
of invulnerability as you teleport
towards or away from danger you'll be
doing a lot of both on insane difficulty
those are some of the best guns you
suggested for insane difficulty we're
willing to go further if you are put
even more of your crazy late-game bills
below and let's get the GameSpot R&D
department cranking out more space guns
in the meantime go check out our video
on the latest patch notes to see if the
googly eyed problem was fixed thanks for
watching pathfinders
[Music]